this argument is always about
vegetarians vegans
Notting Hill Nutters who
who want to change the way the rest of
us eat so let me first of all lay out my
stall I don't give a
I don't give a what you eat any of
you I don't want to make you eat meat I
don't want to stop you eating meat
I don't want to improve your diet
you go and eat whatever you like I'm an
extreme libertarian I just think that
the point of life is to do as much as
you can
as often as you can as freely as you can
that being said
one of the most important things that
ever ever happened to us as a species
was that we ate meat
it GK Chesterton said you know it was a
brave man who first ate an oyster
Willie just wasn't
we all derive from animals that he
didn't eat oysters for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years the
Really Brave man
was the first man that ate a burnt
animal
can you imagine how terrifying that must
have been
all you ever seen a fire is horrifying
and suddenly you come across this thing
that stinks of death and burning
and the Mrs says
bet you wouldn't eat that
but
he does
and it changes
everything
why does it change everything
good
protein
more important than protein cooperation
vegetable eaters do it on their own
meat eaters do it together
eating big bits of meat eating big
animals means cooperation if you cook it
you can feed old people with bad teeth
and young people with no teeth
you can eat a huge amount more
the difference that makes in live births
for your pregnant women in being able to
live three or four years longer and be
productive is enough
to put us in this Hall where they cut up
the first dead body
meat eating is what makes us Cooperative
it's what's make it's actually what
makes dinner parties
that may not be a good thing
the other thing I wanted to say before
we go on I'm more interested in your
questions really than my going on about
about me but I'm I did was have you have
you ever thought about how little how
few things we actually eat
I mean how a few animals we actually eat
very very few
and there's a reason for that
in
to farm animals you have to have the
acquiescence of the animal
you can't farm animals that don't want
to be farmed
it's not us making them do it
they have to see a point in being farm
animals
and not many of them do
guinea pigs
you all keep guinea pigs don't you
eating guinea pigs guinea pigs live in
people's kitchens in Peru Peru in Peru
where they eat corn
yes so they shut corn
goes on the floor guinea pigs eat the
corn
every so often someone goes down beets
are guinea pig on the head and it's the
guinea pig now that works for the guinea
pig because they get a safe environment
they get to have babies they get to
continue to breed they go on and
occasionally one thing gets beaten on
the back of the head but the important
thing is is that outside the kitchen the
peruvians also keep dogs
but the dogs don't live in the kitchen
they live outside the kitchen so the
guinea pigs don't want to go outside the
kitchen
so guinea pigs live in this safe
environment and it's a mutually
successful relationship they go on being
a species they go on and they get eaten
when they get fat
that works for them
the animal that most people wanted to
farm more than anything else right at
the beginning of husbandry
in the
over that great swathe
in Iraq and the Middle East
the animal they were desperate to be
able to farm
were cheetahs
but you would wouldn't you
I mean who'd not want to have a cheetah
you could hunt with it I mean it's as
brilliant desperate to farm with
cheaters
you can't
and they tried for thousands and
thousands of years
and you can do it one at a time if you
find orphaned carbs you can train them
they will live quite happily with people
what cheaters won't do
is they won't live with each other
animals that are farmed have to be able
to live not just with us but with each
other
and they have to do something which is
very specific
which is neotony
this is the ability to remain Forever
Young
it's the ability of a dog
never to go out to be a wolf
so you remain adolescent even though
your body becomes fully grown
you couldn't live with a real wild sheep
that rough
you probably couldn't live with a real
wild cow
Who would know has anyone ever seen a
no you have none of you have the last
one died out in the 17th century
they don't exist anymore
cows made a deal with us
we look after them we'd milk them we'd
Farm them
and they will be one of the most
successful animals in the world
they are the wild ones the ones who went
off
I'm the Jimmy Dean of cows
okay
died in Hungary
appropriately
Pickens
anyway I've seen a wild chicken
I mean I don't mean it's an Angry
Chicken I mean you know like a wild
chick holiday we're not entirely sure
where chickens come from probably from
Far East bit of India jungle fowl
so useless at being Birds
drawing a short story
to us can't fly look stupid
the one thing they had
to get them through to the next
generation was an ability to lay an egg
a day
very few things can do that or would
want to
be made them very useful to us so we
said look it we'll get rid of the
leopards and the dogs and the monkeys
and the Rats we'll lock you up keep you
mostly away from the foxes just keep
laying the eggs one a day anyway is that
it
chickens anyway that's my my bid for
meat eating
[Applause]
I leave it now to George to tell you the
really interesting stuff
thank you